[Musik]
messen für wurst fans gnadenlos hinters
licht und setzt ihn vegetarische
alternativen tour wie die industrie
wurst und fleisch herstellt verriet uns
sebastian
[Musik]
die fleischlose produkte wie fleisch
aussehen zu lassen wie fleisch schmecken
zu lassen bedarf es schon den norma
trickserei getrocknetes hühnereiweiß ist
die hauptzutat dazu kommen bindemittel
die das wasser in der masse
stabilisieren eine kleine brise farbe
wie geschmacksverstärker damit es
richtig ernst wird und dann wird so
schön schmelz ich fertig fleißig wird
kommen riesen tropfen öl dazu das eiweiß
sorgt dafür dass die vegetarische wurst
später eine möglichst fleischige
konsistenz bekommt für den wust
geschmack ist vor allem hefeextrakt
zuständig das wird aus speziellen hefe
rassen gewonnen
der clou das pulver schmeckt besonders
stark nach fleischbrühe das sieht doch
mal wichtig nach wurstpreis oder
entwickelt ich hab den rauer vergessen
ein bisschen flüssig laufen noch eine
runde karussell und alles ist fertig die
teils reichern würde zeit und geld
kosten
richtig schön rauchig ärzte wurst alles
so zaubert ganz echten traum denn bei
vegetarischer burg sind vielmehr
zusatzstoffe erlaubt statt naturdarm
eine hülle aus kunststoff so bleibt die
wurst vegetarisch und besteht vor allem
aus öl und aromen für die industrie
lohnen sich die neuen worten ohne
fleisch wird billiger
kleiner freund mal schöne runde
schwimmen der reise wasserbad bringt die
eiweiße zum stocken so entsteht eine
feste struktur die die wurst erz schnitt
wird macht schon mal drauf was es
geworden ist im anschnitt wurst optisch
kann sebastians kreationen überzeugen
aber schmeckt es auch die richtige
konsistenz zu treffen ist bei der
herstellung einer vegetarischen wurst
die größte herausforderung denn ob eine
wurst den richtigen biss hat oder nicht
erkennen wir im sekunden hat die
industrie den dreh mittlerweile raus das
angebot ist riesig aber schmeckt
vegetarische wurst genauso gut wie
traditionelle das will nelson müller in
essen heraus finden im büro ist
frühstückspause
immer mehr menschen wollen auf fleisch
verzichten aber nicht auf den geschmack
doch können vegetarische wurstprodukte
mit den original mithalten
mit hilfe einer blindverkostung finden
wir dass sätze raus sie bekommen von uns
lediglich die aufgabe den geschmack zu
bewerten
wir wollen wissen kann vegetarische
wurst mithalten und wird sie überhaupt
erkannt haben würde ich sagen an die
wurst und fertig los
extra von die ohne eine fleischwurst mit
gurke dafür boni fleisch also gewürze
kommen durch sieht ansprechend aus dem
niveau ist ist total überzeugend das ist
richtig leicht frisch sommerlich top
schön ist kandidat nummer zwei ist eine
salami von wiesenhof aus echtem
geflügelfleisch überzeugt sie mit
intensiven fleischgeschmack von der
farbe ist es für mich keine salami zu
ich finde es schmeckt auch ein bisschen
künstlich sagt also dass da würde ich
mir zu auch nicht kaufen
weiter geht es mit einer salami von
rügenwalder wieder vegetarisch fällt das
auf
[Musik]
ich find den top also die würde ich
tatsächlich auch kaufen die überzeugt
durch mit allem also sowieso mehr als
diese pinky version hat so einen
eigenartigen beigeschmack
ok den ich nicht ganz deuten kann aber
so etwas zu fleischig könnte ja sein
dass irgendein anderes von einem anderen
tier stammt als man es eigentlich
gewöhnt ist wo ist nun mal viel die bio
leone von edeka mit fleisch das ist die
klassische modell wird ich sag erinnert
mich an meine kindheit das ist das was
man mal so beim schlachter auf die hand
gekriegt hat eine kleine scheibe so hat
nicht so schmeckt dass das ist auch
immer hatte ich danke dir immer ja erst
mal auf platz eins und schmeckt gut in
könnt ihr die gewürzmischung gut dass es
nicht zu salzig nicht zulassen bei mir
gerade die mit dem gewürzgurken weiß was
besonderes ist was ich vorher noch nie
hatte was sehr frisch geschmeckt hat
ganz klar bei mir die nummer eins die
marke fand ich also auch sehr gut
spitzenreiter ist auch hier das gärtchen
ganz klar bei bürste machen das rennen
unter sich aus die ebk bio leone mit und
land hofburg ein extra ohne fleisch
[Musik]
in eurem ranking wenn ich es sehe ist
der überwiegende teil vegetarische wurst
design ami auch hättet ihr damit
gerechnet hätte ich jetzt nicht erwartet
also die wurst sowie ihr dachte dass es
mal ein anderes tier gewesen sein könnte
war eine vegetarische wusste in
deutschland hat sich eine unglaublich
große vielfalt an wurstspezialitäten
herausgebildet jeder gute metzger bietet
mittlerweile regionale spezialitäten an
doch leider findet man in supermärkten
und discountern relativ wenig davon
stattdessen gibt es immer mehr
vegetarische produkte das ist zum einen
gut für die vielfalt und sogar
geschmacklich können sie mithalten
habt ihr eine lieblingswurst sagt es uns
in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr in euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonnier die zdf
besser esser und schauten die nixen zwei
clips